BUT FIRST.
>> NO EXPERIENCE UNDER
WHATSOEVER I WILL BEAR FALSE
WITNESS AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
NOR WILL I MAKE UP LIES TO EASE
THE PRESSURE ON MYSELF.
>> Laura: FORMER TRUMP ADVISOR
ROGER STONE LOOKING LIKE HE JUST
CAME OFF THE GOLF COURSE, COMING
OUT OF THE COURTROOM DEFIANT, HE
WILL NOT TESTIFY AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT AFTER BOB MUELLER SENT
A SWARM OF ARMED FBI AGENTS TO
HIS HOUSE BEFORE THE SUN WAS UP.
NOW, STONE REMAINED RESOLUTE
EARLIER WITH OUR OWN TUCKER
CARLSON.
>> I WILL NOT QUIT.
I WILL NOT FOLD.
I WILL NOT BEND.
I WILL NOT BEAR FALSE WITNESS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
I INTEND TO FIGHT.
BECAUSE THIS INDICTMENT IS, IS,
IS FABRICATED.
>> Laura: WITH ME NOW IS ROGER
STONE'S LAWYER, TYLER NIXON.
TYLER, THANKS FOR BEING HERE,
YOU HAVE HAD A LONG DAY.
I WANT TO READ FROM THE
INDICTMENT AND GET YOUR
REACTION.
A QUOTE, AFTER THE JULY 22nd,
2016 RELEASE OF STOLEN DNC
E-MAILS BY ORGANIZATION ONE,
WHICH WE HAVE LEARNED IS
WIKILEAKS, A SENIOR TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OFFICIAL WAS DIRECTED
TO CONTACT STONE ABOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL RELEASES, AND WHAT
OTHER DAMAGING INFORMATION,
ORGANIZATION ONE HAD REGARDING
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
TYLER, WHO DIRECTED THAT
CAMPAIGN OFFICIAL?
>> WELL, THAT'S A MYSTERY THAT I
THINK REMAINS TO BE SEEN AND
REMAINS TO BE DISCOVERED.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON,
APPRECIATE IT, IT'S BEEN A LONG
DAY FOR SURE.
THIS WITCH HUNT HAS BEEN GOING
ON, HAS BEEN TAKEN TO THE
EXTREME.
AND AS WE KNOW, ROGER WAS CARTED
OFF FROM HIS HOME, EARLY RAID,
PRE-DAUNL RAID, IN A MANNER THAT
WAS -- PRE-DAWN RAID THAT WAS
REMINISCENT OF A POLICE STATE
RATHER THAN A FREE REPUBLIC.
IT WAS DISGRACEFUL.
YOU AND I SHARE, I BELIEVE, THE
ALMA MATER OF HER MUELLER, THE
UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA LAW
SCHOOL, I THINK MR. JEFFERSON
WOULD BE STANDING WITH MR. STONE
RATHER THAN ROBERT MUELLER.
IT'S HARD TO SAY, THERE'S SO
MUCH FABRICATION AND SO MUCH
INSIN U ASIAN THAT --
INSINUATION THAT'S GONE ON.
I'VE KNOWN ROGER FOR YEARS.
THIS IS JUST, REALLY
KAFKE-ESQUE, A LYNCH MOB.
>> Laura: A LOT OF PEOPLE
WATCHING FOX TONIGHT, THEY'RE
WORRIED.
I MEAN, THEY'RE WORRIED A FRIEND
OF TRUMP'S ARRESTED IN A
PREDAUNL RAID, RIDICULOUS, I WAS
A CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEY,
CASE LIKE THIS, YOU NOTIFY YOU,
THEY WOULD HAVE CALLED YOU UP
AND SAID WE'RE GOING TO BRING
HIM N IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ARRANGED NO, BIG DEAL.
IF HE WAS GOING TO DESTROY
DOCUMENTS HE'S HAD, LIKE, TWO
YEARS TO DO IT F THAT'S WHAT HE
WANTED TO DO.
PATENTLY ABSURD.
ALL TO PUT PRESSURE ON HIM.
I'VE SEEN THIS TACTIC SO MANY
TIMES IN THE PAST IT'S PALT
INTERESTLY OBVIOUS.
WE'VE -- PATENTLY OBVIOUS.
ON THE FACTS OF THIS, LYING TO
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS,
LYING TO ANY FEDERAL OFFICIAL,
IT'S A PROCESS CRIME BUT ALSO A
CRIME.
DID YOUR CLIENT COMMIT A CRIME
IN ANSWERING QUESTIONS ABOUT
DOCUMENTS THAT HE HAD IN HIS
POSSESSION THAT MIGHT HAVE VINLD
KATED -- INDICATED AN INTENT TO
FACILITATE RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
IN THE ELECTION?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT, LAURA.
I MEAN, THIS HAS BEEN HASHED
OVER BY ROGER HIMSELF, OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THE BOTTOM LINE, I REVIEWED HIS
TESTIMONY, WHICH BY THE WAY HAS
BEEN HELD SECRET IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, THE
BOULS OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE SINCE DECEMBER OF
2017, ALLOWING THEM TO
MISCHARACTERIZE THE TESTIMONY
AND CHARACTERIZE MR. STONE AS
HAVING LIED, PURCHASE INJURED
HIMSELF AS -- PERJURIED HIMSELF
AS THE CASE MAY BE, STILL YET TO
BE RELEASED.
YET IT WAS RELEASED TO ROBERT
MUELLER.
ROGER GAVE TRUTH R TRUTHFUL
ANSWERS AND ACCURATE ANSWERS
WITH THE INFORMATION HE HAD AT
THE TIME.
IN THE INTERIM TIME, THERE HAS
BEEN DISCOVERED MATERIALS,
INCLUDING A CELL PHONE WHICH
CONTAINED TEXTS, FOR EXAMPLE,
WITH RANDY CREDICO WHICH
EXONERATED ROGER.
ROGER STATED THAT RANDY WAS THE
INTERMEDIARY.
>> Laura: HE DENIES THAT.
DIDN'T HE TELL --
>> CREDICO HAS DENIED IT ALL
ALONG.
HE HAS LIED ALL ALONG.
THERE ARE TEXTS THAT CLEARLY
SHOW THAT, YES, HE ABSOLUTELY
WAS DISCUSSING WIKILEAKS.
>> Laura: THEY HAVE THAT.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
MORNING, I WOKE UP WAY TOO EARLY
FOR HAVING A LATE SHOW AND SAW
THIS THING BLOWING UP.
I SEE THE AGENTS IN, THERE LIKE
BANGING ON THE DOOR, LIKE A TV
SHOW, BANGING ON THE DOOR,
"FBI," SOME ONE IS GOING TO PULL
OUT AN UZI ON THEM.
I FELT BAD, IT WAS PATHETIC.
WHEN THEY GO IN THERE, ROGER IS
IN HIS BATHROBE, PAJAMAS.
WHAT HAPPENED THEN, TELL ME,
THEY READ HIM HILLS RIGHTS,
OBVIOUSLY, WHAT DID THEY START
GOING THROUGH?
THEY WERE THERE FOR HOURS.
PULLING UP FLOOR BOARDS, CEILING
PANELS, GOING THROUGH HARD
DRIVES OBVIOUSLY, WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I'M AT A DISADVANTAGE NOT
BEING ON THE GROUND IN FLORIDA,
I HAVEN'T GOTTEN THESE DETAILS,
DEALING WITH OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE CASE.
>> Laura: YOU HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE
DETAILS ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN
YOUR CLIENT'S HOUSE?
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN BACK TO HIS HOUSE YET.
THEY WERE STILL GOING THROUGH
IT.
>> Laura: I WAS WONDERING IF
THEY GAVE YOU ANY INDICATION --
HE HASN'T BEEN BACK TO THE
HOUSE?
NEWS MEDIA ALL OVER THE PLACE.
REGULAR AMERICANS WANT TO KNOW,
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT COMES AFTER
YOU, RIGHTLY OR WRONGLY, WHAT
HAPPENS INSIDE THE HOUSE.
I'VE SEEN IT, THEY PICK UP
EVERYTHING, GO THROUGH
EVERYTHING.
BUT THEY WERE THERE FOR HOURS.
TONIGHT, HOW IS YOUR CLIENT
DOING?
WE SAW HIM ON TUCKER, HOW IS HE
DOING, FEEL LIKE HE'S IN LEGAL
JEOPARDY?
ALAN DERSHOWITZ, I HAVE TO PLAY
THIS FOR YOU, TONIGHT, HE SPOKE
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
FLIPPING YOUR CLIENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> STONE DOESN'T STRIKE ME AS
THE KIND OF GUY WHO'S GOING TO
EASILY COOPERATE.
BUT LOOK, WHEN YOU'RE FACING
LONG PRISON TERM, THE MOST LOYAL
OF PEOPLE TURN TO THEMSELVES AND
SAY, I HAVE TO LOOK OUT FOR
MYSELF FIRST.
COHEN SAID HE WOULD NEVER
TESTIFY AGAINST TRUMP, HE WOULD
TAKE BULL LET FOR HIM.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN THE PERSON IS
ARRESTED FOR A MYRIAD OF CRIMES.
>> Laura: TYLER, REACTION.
>> ROGER STONE, HE HAS SAID
REPEATEDLY THAT HE WOULD NOT
BEAR FALSE WITNESS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE COULD HAVE TO
DO -- WOULD HAVE TO DO TO
IMPLICATE THE PRESIDENT.
THERE IS NO RUSSIAN COLLUSION,
THERE IS NO CONSPIRACY WITH
WIKILEAKS, NOTHING THAT'S BEEN
CONTRIVED OUT OF THIN AIR, IN
THIS WITCH HUNT, THIS HOAX IS
WHAT IT IS.
HE WOULD NOT DO THAT.
HE'S NOT MICHAEL COHEN.
ROGER STONE, IRONICALLY AS YOU
KNOW IS REALLY ONE OF THE MOST
HONEST PEOPLE THAT YOU'LL FIND
IN POLITICS, HE'S TRUTHFUL ABOUT
HIMSELF AND WHAT HE DOES AND WHO
HE IS.
>> Laura: HE'S BEEN AROUND FOR A
LONG TIME, A VERY INTERESTING
AND COLORFUL PAST.
SO DO ALL OF US.
BUT I HAVE TO, IF YOU READ HIS
LAST BOOK YOU LEARN MORE ABOUT
HIS THINKING, WORRIED ABOUT HIS
FINANCIAL SITUATION, YOU GET
PAID, LAWYERS COST A LOT OF
MONEY.
TYLER, YOU COULD HAVE GONE ON
ANY SHOW TONIGHT, WE REALLY,
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU JOINING